there really isn't another place that
I'd rather live and another place that
you can get the kind of inspiration that
you can get here there's so many
different cultures here how everything
kind of meets in it's pulling from all
these different directions I think gives
people a unique perception on the world
and a unique vantage point there's not
too many other places you can go on
earth and have all of the different
dynamics of the city of Los Angeles
our personal story is synonymous with
the downtown story we were an emerging
company we had no real history and
nobody really believed in it people
don't think it would get to where it is
now we're the emerging brain coming out
of downtown we want to plant our roots
in LA and really make the city ours you
go to each different city across the
world and each place has its own style
I think la is that perfect blend it's
more casual but it's an elevated casual
aesthetic I'm pretty particular about a
lot of things I really like VirB coffee
I like the nitro cold brew I love to
work out
I love playing ping pong I love bowling
[Music]
to me Los Angeles the grocery in the
world there's so many different types of
people here we travel all the time but
there's no better feeling than landing
back in LA